all right thank you all for the applause
thank you thank you
yes all right so this is a very very
special edition of beginner breakdown
tonight we are commemorating our six
year anniversary here at the Chess Club
in scholastic center of st. Louis and
tonight we have a guest mr. Tim Meecham
he was my opponent for for this game and
it's a stellar game wasn't it yeah it
sure was yeah it was great all right and
and you oh yeah yeah yeah I get to that
yeah
so Tim be nice you're short in a Simon
using the Sicilian kind yeah yeah well
it was great it was great and he was so
nice he sat down I had the white piece
here the black pieces he told me that
right before we played yeah so that was
a great idea always tell your opponent
what you're going to play your pet
opening that you can be grandmasters
with it right before you sit down and
play all right so here we go here's the
game I start out a four and Tim plays
the Sicilian c5 and now I play c3 yeah
you sure word wish and I play Knight f3
so you could go into the kana huh but I
didn't cuz you told me how good you were
it's a pretty good move there so what
did you think about that move uh Tim
whoa whoa it's a family show you want me
to stick that bishop where whoa a
countdown all right calm down here
calm down so if he plays King to g8 you
know I can I can get safe but mr. Nisha
he had a plan and he's like I'm sticking
with it right I don't know why I mean I
just played east six the stop it so when
he plays King to g8 even this kid has
only been playing for three months knows
the move I'm gonna make right seven so
we
see stop easy so I don't know what you
were thinking about yeah yeah so hey he
takes with Shaq
alright he's took the stuck piece with
check see when people are really really
angry all the time they tend to make bad
moves like like yeah your feelings were
a little hurt when I took took your
you're putting took your pawn on g5 huh
so so he wanted to get me back I
actually think and calculate out you
just thought you were winning huh but
you didn't have any proof I actually
calculated out and I calculated out all
the variations and I just can sit back
and relax because I know I know I've won
now so now I'm threatening rook takes
pawn and also Shaq all right
so pretty scary so guess who's got to go
to e8 now guess who's got to go to yeah
just a little late
just a little late h4 it excellent
alright so here we go here we go so h4
it so now it's getting tough what do you
think I should play here nope nope nope
mister new show it's not rook to g4
check nope because those checks would
actually help me alright help you get
over there you see you see oh don't get
so mad about it's just the game is the
game it's just the game all right all
right well thank you for coming mr.
nation
sorry you guys had to see that okay but
uh but yeah game over okay
and that was the infamous game and I won
the game and I won the tournament and
leaving Tim Nisha I'm just a half point
behind